[Music]
hi guys
it's quinn here if you appreciate my
content then please click the like
button on this video
it really helps out so that the youtube
algorithm circulates my videos when i
upload
i imagine that most of you have heard of
the fermi paradox
it basically asks the question why don't
we see other intelligent life in the
universe besides ourselves
in 1961 frank drake wrote what is now
known
as the drake equation it attempts to
calculate the probability
of finding other intelligent life in the
universe
the drake equation is as follows the
number of technologically advanced
civilizations in the universe is
equivalent to the rate
of the formation of stars in the galaxy
multiplied by the fraction of stars
with planetary systems multiplied by the
fraction of planets
with environments suitable for life
multiplied by the fraction of planets on
which life
actually appears multiplied by the
fraction of living planets
which give birth to intelligent life
multiplied by the fraction of
civilizations
that manage to develop technologies and
release detectable evidence of their
existence into space
multiplied by the length of time said
civilizations continue to release signs
of their existence into space
i wrote down all the things you needed
to know to predict how hard it's going
to be
to detect extraterrestrial life and
looking
at them it became pretty evident that if
you multiplied all these together
you got a number in which is the number
of detectable civilizations in our
galaxy
frank drake 1961.
essentially if you apply the drake
equation the result would indicate that
the universe should be teeming with
observable life but somehow the universe
as we know it appears to be empty
this is the fermi paradox if the
universe should be full of life
then where is said life because of this
idea
the concept of a great filter was
introduced
the great filter is simply whatever
thing that prevents
life from entering the stage where it
can be detected by other civilizations
this could be because there is some
deadly factor about the universe that we
do not know or understand
which is ultimately lethal to life
before it can become a galactic faring
civilization
or it could be because advanced
civilizations are ultimately
self-destructive
humanity seems to have a bright future
i.e
a non-trivial chance of expanding to
fill the universe with lasting life but
the fact that space nearest seems dead
now
tells us that any given piece of dead
matter faces an
astronomically low chance of beginning
such a future
there thus exist a great filter between
death and
expanding lasting life and humanity
faces the ominous question
how far along this filter are we robin
hansen the great filter
are we almost past it 1998
in previous videos we have discussed the
existence of aliens in the dune universe
officially there are no aliens at all in
the series
although humankind has the ability to
fold space
traveling nearly instantaneously between
worlds
alien life has never been found on other
planets
the only exception is potentially the
sand worms
though it is not explicitly stated that
they were
forms of alien life they could have for
instance been the result of genetic
manipulation of animals originating from
old earth
now frank herbert's decision not to
include aliens in the dune saga
is widely accepted to be intentional he
wanted his story to focus on humanity
entirely but this does not prevent us
from discussing dune
and the context of the fermi paradox
we've also previously discussed krelizek
in previous videos on this channel
kralozak also known as the typhoon
struggle
is a friend myth about a great testing
event for humanity in the future
i think it seems likely that the typhoon
struggle relates to the coming of the
enemy
god emperor lato ii saw coming for
humanity and its future
his entire 4000 year reign was meant to
prepare humanity for the struggle
against that enemy
and ensure their indefinite survival
when considering the idea of this great
enemy i can't help but be reminded of
the concept of the great filter
many have guessed at what lato's great
enemy could potentially be
but it seems clear to me that it is of
human origin
as i said dune is a human story
in the book god emperor of dune later
the second mentions seeking machines
capable of hunting down and killing all
humans who did not have the ability to
hide from prescient sight
seeking machines is almost certainly a
reference to hunter seeker devices
only more advanced science fiction
including dune often warns about the
reckless pursuit of technology
if humankind likely the ixians managed
to create
a killing device with prescient
capabilities
and set it loose upon humanity it is
likely that it would eventually move
beyond their control
perhaps the dune saga is suggesting that
the great filter
is caused by the fact that
technologically advanced species
ultimately created technologies that
were destructive to themselves
when a species grows large enough it
eventually begins to act as a super
organism
no individual within that organism can
control the whole
once the magic and horror of technology
is unleashed
it cannot be contained again the army
fostered technology because the power of
machines appeared so obvious to the
short-sighted
that lasegun is no more than a machine
but all machines fail or are superseded
still the army worships at the shrine of
such things
both fascinated and fearful look at how
people fear the ixians
in its guts the army knows it is the
sorcerer's apprentice
it unleashes technology and never again
can the magic be stuffed back into the
bottle
but even that wouldn't really explain
the lack of any life whatsoever on any
of the worlds explored in the dune saga
but perhaps this fact reflects the
actual size of the universe
perhaps the demon universe is in fact
full of alien life
but it is so big that the likelihood
that humans will ever discover it
is minuscule or the answer is simply
that within the dune universe
life is a lot less common than our own
so therefore the drake equation
wouldn't apply or perhaps the answer is
even more sinister
i am reminded of the story of the
starship known as the ampolyris
which is featured in the dune
encyclopedia i also covered this story
in my aliens in dune video
the crew of the ampolyris all apparently
went insane
heading off in pursuit of some invisible
alien adversary
one they believe sought to destroy all
humanity
there is no evidence that what they
believed was accurate
but also no solid explanation for why
the entire crew suddenly went mad
sharing the same delusions if frank
herbert's great enemy wasn't actually
human created
as i think is the most likely could it
have been some other
sinister and unseen threat perhaps there
are dark things out there in the
universe
that we will never consciously perceive
could this be
the true great filter of the dune saga a
powerful
shadow threat that sought to destroy
humankind
and perhaps other potential alien life
as well
well i think it's unlikely to suggest
this would require a few
leaps there's no indication that such a
thing exists
anywhere else in the books daniel and
marty
the seemingly multi-dimensional advanced
face dancers who show up in frank
herbert's final two dune books
heretics of dune and chapter house tune
are the closest thing to resembling what
the m polaris
crew described but these face dancers
wouldn't appear until
thousands of years after the ampolyris
was said to have existed
and there is no solid evidence that any
form of time travel is among their
capabilities
the god emperor's reference to seeking
machines and the ixian potential
creation of arafel
aka the cloud darkness of holy judgment
also seems to pretty clearly suggest
that the threat against humanity relates
to a prescient
man-created machine now if you have read
brian herbert's books
sand worms of dune and hunters of dune
then you know that
this concept is handled in a way in
those books
but whether or not these ideas align
with frank herbert's initial ones
is arguable in conclusion
in the dune universe we are essentially
our own
great filter we have the power to save
ourselves by recognizing the patterns of
history
and learning from the mistakes of our
ancestors
and by being cautious in our endless
quest for innovation
the human species must evolve mentally
as a super organism before we can ever
hope to
successfully wield potentially deadly
technology without detriment to our own
species
thank you guys so much for watching make
sure you like and subscribe for more
quinn's ideas
and check out my channel for more
science fiction videos
so i'm currently reading the remembrance
of earth past trilogy by sixteen lu
i think that's how you pronounce this
name forgive me if i didn't pronounce it
correctly
and it's great it's probably one of the
best modern science fiction series that
i've
ever read i intend to start discussing
the books pretty soon on my channel
and the idea of a great filter is
definitely something that appears in
those books as well
if you have any other science fiction
books that you'd like me to take a look
at i'd love to hear your suggestions
just leave a comment below this video or
shoot me a tweet thanks guys